so we're hiring at think media and in
this video I'm going to be breaking down
the four positions that are open and
sharing with you the five things that we
look for and think team members and
actually if you just are watching this
and not sure if you'd want to work here
or not I think you're going to love the
five tips because they're going to help
you make more money at your current job
they're good insights for leaders if you
want to build your own team and it's
going to be a short and fun video but if
you want to apply to think media we are
hiring you can go to workwiththink.com
and on that website what you're going to
see is the four positions that are open
up right now now we're actually going to
be hiring throughout the year and so if
you want to check out
um Anytime work with think.com then you
can apply to be a part of a team of
Purpose Driven creators marketers and
entrepreneurs and we are hiring a social
media manager a Content coordinator a
director of operations and a marketing
video editor and so check out
workwiththink.com but here's the five
things that we look for and thank team
members number one character
this one should be obvious but it's the
five C's of think media and character is
the foundation of all other virtues
that's like a trust thing you know if we
can't trust you then how could you how
could we work with you and so uh number
one is we look for character that's
that's why we check references you know
that's why it's about like uh what's
your reputation you know and it's those
foundations that actually are just
should be a pre-whack a requisite right
character shouldn't be surprising it
should be like wow that's special the
per you know what I mean it's just kind
of like Integrity trust being a person
of your word being able to show up on
time all that kind of stuff the second
one though is chemistry are you a good
fit for the think media culture this is
why we have an interview process so if
you apply today
you come over you're going to fill out
like if you want to be the content
coordinator we're looking for a
full-time position for someone that is
going to be a part of our creative team
responsible for YouTube channels and
podcasts in support of Nolan malt and in
support of Omar and uh Kyle Anderson and
myself anyways so you know when you fill
that out of course chemistry is just you
might be incredible and we might be
super weird but we just don't Vibe you
know so our team is has got a real
family Vibe and we have a cool culture
and so ultimately it's just like are you
a good fit here doesn't make somebody
wrong or right it's just trying to
figure out if you would if you would
vibe with us we would vibe with you
that's kind of part of the interview
process number three is competency are
you able to get the job done to be clear
this is not an internship these are uh
real positions where you can see the
details you know if you need prior
experience and you know full-time
contractor W-2 you can see the deadlines
on here you're going to see a lot of
specific detail and so you know we've
dreamed about doing an internship or
things like that
and uh you know a chance to work with
think and be immersed and learn here and
of course we have a very leadership
personal development continuous growth
culture but
for these roles it's just candy get the
job done do you have the skill set do
you understand the software if necessary
do you have the experience if necessary
and you can see that for the specific
positions I mean for example underneath
the social media manager you you I was
just looking at you know proficiency and
things like slackmoney.com canva Excel
zoom and those types of things the past
experience and social media
administrative or project management
roles things like that so that's the
third C that is competency we're going
through the five C's that we look for in
think media team members I have two more
and and if you want to apply for any of
the positions open at think media go to
work with think.com now I am streaming
this video live and if you have a
question
um shoot four question marks before and
after the question and I would love to
answer any questions in case anything
I'm sharing isn't detailed and clear but
number four is capacity it's a little
bit different than maybe other teams and
I want to encourage you if you're just
watching this and getting value from
this video this is one of the most
important C's skill sets and details
just in the modern world so number one
to recap character you know can we trust
you it's the foundation of all other
virtues number two are you a good fit
here chemistry number three competency
can you get the job done number four are
you able to work fast and handle
pressure it's not just can you get the
job done can you actually get the job
done fast
here's some things about think media if
you're looking for a place where things
never change do not apply to think media
if you're looking to be a part of a team
in an industry where you can just count
on six months from now being the same as
today do not apply to think media we are
in a world YouTube digital marketing
it's a fast-paced industry and our
values at think media Are Family
run and rest we say a lot like we we
Sprint really hard but we also really
value rest but no doubt about it we work
fast we hustle when we need to and we
adapt and pivot because things are
happening quickly in our industry you
know I have a background in the church
world
and so sometimes you'd have somebody
that's maybe creating content or you
know a commercial for the weekend some
type of a video and it was like what'd
you do with your you know 40-hour week
to somebody on the media team or
something and they're like yeah you know
well this is the video I got done and I
was like wait a minute the the singular
video you got done
you did one video this week
you should have done 26 videos this week
I mean not even just like two like you
should have and and I understand that
sometimes maybe a video could take an
entire week but you get what I'm like
the level of outputs the level of being
able to work fast the level of being
able to think a lot bigger than maybe
the average person thinks like they get
one task done in a day you know this is
a world where we're comfortable with
like create the vertical video post it
on Instagram take it over to Facebook
hit it on LinkedIn optimize the YouTube
posts like able to tactically these
positions are different
but what's Your Capacity I just want to
encourage you it's a little bit of
insight of what's happening at think
media are you able to work fast
and are you able to handle pressure are
you able to be under deadlines or or be
able to if something pivots respond to
that that's the fourth C that's a big
one and it's not just number three
competency can you do the job number
four it's can you do the job quickly and
then number five is courage are you
ready to step out on a bold adventure
you know I think media our goal is to be
courageous we don't want to be afraid of
peoples what people think what people's
opinions are I mean of course we deeply
love our community and our customers but
in a world where you get all kinds of
critics and you know people could be in
the comment section or people got
opinions about what you're doing we are
a bold future focused
visioneering on a mission company that
is looking for courageous people that
want to be a part of a movement we want
courageous people that want to be a part
of a bigger Mission we want courageous
people that aren't just looking for a
complacent comfortable job but are
looking to be a part of something
significant and so our fifth C is
courage and so those are the five C's
and uh here's Tony good to see you man I
can't recommend
think media enough Tony was a part of
our team an absolute Legend one of our
video record Academy members and uh now
he's doing some incredible stuff in the
film industry and for the XFL and all
kind of stuff and so by the way too you
know you could see that in some of these
positions we want
um to be connecting with you you know
hopefully for a while we're looking for
a place where you can plant some roots
and invest here and grow and have
provision for your family and have a
learning environment where you're
growing but we also understand that we
hope our vision is big enough that your
vision can live inside of us what we
vision can live inside of it and that
you can flourish here but also we want
to be a launching pad not a a lid or a
limitation to the people that work at
think media and so it's so cool to see
how people like Tony people like Chris
people like Alina have worked at think
and then launched into you know really
cool uh projects and jobs of their own
and and uh Futures and side hustles and
all kinds of stuff that they started and
so whether it's part-time or full-time
um I see that uh some of y'all are
asking about that head over to
workwiththink.com and you can see the
details of the jobs
um that's a good question some of the
deadlines were on March 1st and I
understand we're just getting this video
to you now we've kind of been gearing up
to uh launch this and so yes you you can
still apply so so I am giving you that
green light and I'll make sure that I'm
this video is internally shared as well
um and you can see that inside uh of
there
um if you live in Colombia check each
individual job description to see if you
can apply if you're not in the U.S
that's potentially okay but but I guess
you know you saw it Mary it is U.S only
it's also time zone is a big deal for us
we do have people that are all over but
we are trying to even though we are a
remote team we are trying to keep a real
synchronicity amongst uh us our team and
so we're being a little bit more
thoughtful of that but there are
different positions and there's going to
be other positions in the future so if
you're watching this video just go to
workwiththink.com and you can always see
any open positions if you can do me a
favor hit like on uh this video so that
it gets shared out there and uh head to
work with think.com for the to apply for
any of the open four positions and we'll
talk soon